you might be wondering how a lecture
about fungal infections could be so
interesting
well I'll be telling you about
situations that could place any of us at
risk of acquiring a fungal infection
even events has benign as creating a
flower arrangement or going on a camping
trip
let's start learning about fungal
infections with a camping trip scenario
let's imagine you're going to spend part
of your summer vacation with your son or
grandson and a Boy Scout trip to
Northern Wisconsin
now this trip includes several nights at
a camp near the Eagle River
the camp has 40 acres of Pine and
Hemlock forest and there are over 6 000
visitors to the camp annually who
participate in all types of outdoor
activities including lectures and
ecology projects
there are four cabins for overnight
guests and the meals are prepared and
served in the dining hall on the
campgrounds
let's also suppose that six or eight
weeks after your stay your son or
grandson becomes ill with a fever a dry
cough and chest pain
he's taken to his pediatrician where a
diagnosis of walking pneumonia is made
and he's prescribed an
erythromycin-based antibiotic
several of the boy's friends who are
also Scouts are ill with similar
symptoms
however the families don't make much of
this connection since the boys are
frequently playing together
a health officer at the Wisconsin Public
Health Department is getting an unusual
number of case reports of elementary
school students visiting their primary
care physicians with fever severe cough
chest pain and this diagnosis of quote
walking pneumonia
eventually speedom specimens are coughed
up from several sick children that show
an unusual finding under the microscope
chest x-rays are taken and reveal
multiple nodular appearing spots in the
lungs
what's your diagnosis
if you think it's a virus a bacteria
will make our diagnosis a little bit
later
although fungal diseases usually don't
involve humans they can indirectly
involve humans and they've played a
major role in human history
a less well-known outbreak of disease
the Irish Potato Famine began in 1845.
the fungus killed off Ireland's potato
crops and more than a million people
died of starvation and illness brought
on by malnutrition
the potato was the basic Staple in the
Irish diet so when potatoes turned into
a slimy decaying pile of rot many
theories abounded
one was this was a result of static
electricity from the new railroad
locomotives
but actually the cause was an airborne
fungus that had traveled from Mexico to
Ireland in the holds of ships traveling
to Ireland
the fungus was destroying the roots of
the potato plant
and even back then global trade was
affecting the health of people all over
the world
besides hunger many people died from
diseases associated with malnutrition
which indirectly causes deficiencies in
the immune system making those affected
more prone to infectious diseases
in 1861 a scientist proved that a fungus
caused the blight disease
the fungus still causes disease in
potatoes in other countries
a more destructive fungal strain than
the 1840s Irish potato one is
threatening potato fields in Russia
[Music]
fungi are eukaryotic cells containing a
nucleus and many organelles
these are more complicated life forms
they require oxygen to live
and fungi are structurally divided into
yeasts similar to the yeast used in
baking bread
and molds the green circles on moldy
pieces of bread in the refrigerator or
blocks of cheese that you find in the
back of the refrigerator
molds are actually composed of many
hyphal elements now hyphy are
thread-like branching tubules composed
of fungal cells attached end to end
most fungi are either a yeast or a mole
however there are some fungi that are
dimorphic they exist in one shape in the
human body and a different shape in
laboratory culture media
a yeast is a unicellular form of fungal
growth
these cells can appear spherical or
elliptical
and they reproduce by budding
spores are the reproducing bodies of
molds
cell membranes of fungi are also more
complex than those of bacteria
the outer cell contains a building block
called ergosterol
now ergosterol is similar in structure
to cholesterol which is an ingredient of
human cell membranes
this can be important since some
anti-fungal medications may have side
effects that are associated with the
structural similarity between ergosterol
and cholesterol
now here's a personal example of a
fungal infection that could happen to
almost anyway
years ago the Yale golf coach called me
on the phone saying that both of his
hands had swollen to enormous
proportions such that he could no longer
even grip a golf club
he had returned four weeks earlier from
teaching younger golfers in Saint
Andrews Scotland where he
uncharacteristically had plotted through
the Scottish Heather looking for their
golf balls
complaining to his primary physician he
received a course of oral antibiotics
but his hands were not getting any
better
over the phone I was suspicious about a
fungal infection since he had many
scratches on the back of his hands from
the Scottish Heather bushes
and he had not responded to antibiotics
now since he was returning to Saint
Andrews for more golf instruction in a
few weeks it was imperative that I
helped him with his diagnosis and
treatment
I called in a long distance prescription
for an anti-fungal medication and after
four weeks of treatment I was pleased to
find out that he was cured
and I'll explain this fungal condition
shortly
fungal infections are generally
characterized by the depth of invasion
into the human body
there are surface-based skin infections
infections underneath the skin
body weight infections associated with
specific Geographic areas
and then infections in patients with
compromised immune systems
I'd now like to introduce you to the
fungal infections of the skin surfaces
and of hair and nails these are known as
dermatophytes
these fungi live in the dead outside
layers of the skin hair and the nails
now keratin is the primary structural
protein of these body components
and dermatified secrete an enzyme
carotenase which partially digests
layers of these body components
the disruption of keratin causes the
loss of hair
scaling in the skin and crumbling of the
nails
and when the nails are involved the term
is known as onychomycosis
this leads to thickened discolored and
brittle nails
fungal nail infections do become more
prevalent as we age and about half of
adults over the age of 70 are affected
superficial fungal infections are also
nicknamed as tinia so tinea corporis
forms a ring shape with a red raised
border and is known as ringworm
when these dermatophytes involve the
scalp they're known as tinea capitus
when they involve the foot they're known
as tineopetis causing quote athlete's
foot
The Athlete's Foot causes cracking and
peeling of skin between the toes
moving deeper into the skin
subcutaneous fungal infections usually
enter the body following injury to the
skin rather than a digestive enzyme
they usually remain localized to the
tissues just below the top layers of the
skin or spread to local lymph nodes
one important yeast that can cause an
either superficial or subcutaneous
fungal infection is known as Candida
albicans
and candida species like bacteria are
part of the body's normal microbiota
when antibiotics can kill the bacteria
but not the yeast candida can take over
and expand their growth without
competition
Canada causes diaper rash in newborns as
well as overgrowth in the vaginal area
after antibiotics while leading to a
white discharge
or sometimes we see a white pattern in
the mouth known as oral thrush after
antibiotic therapy
candida can also be involved in
body-wide infections in patients who are
hospitalized and subjected to extensive
antibiotic therapy and invasive medical
devices such as intravenous catheters
now the Yale golf coach's hand
infections were caused by
sporotrichosis considered a subcutaneous
yeast
but I'd like to tell you a slightly
different story about this fungus
in Wisconsin several years ago the
health department was notified of four
employees at a garden center with
suspected sporoticosis
all four were involved in making floral
arrangements for grave sites
each had developed an ulcerative lesion
on the hand or the wrist that was
originally thought to be a bacterial
infection
next they developed an ascending
infection of the lymph system
and fungal cultures from the lymph nodes
grew sporal thricks
when investigators finally connected the
dots the four employees were cured with
an oral anti-fungal medicine known as
Ketoconazole
so what was the common culprit
well samples of the sphagnumos used
during the production of the floral
arrangements at the Garden Center were
tested and were positive for sporal
thricks the sphangna Moss had been
harvested from bogs located in Central
Wisconsin and was purchased from one
wholesale dealer
other cases in the midwest occurred
related to the distribution of the Moss
now this case suggests that workers in
contact with moss could reduce their
risk of acquiring Disease by wearing
protective clothing but particularly
protective gloves
Spore tricosis can also result from
injuries associated with handling of
contaminated firewood or rose thorns so
if you're a gardener you should take
extra care and wear gloves while
handling roses
as an infectious disease clinician I
have had one case of even a snowmobile
driver who acquired sport tracosis after
scraping against a rusty fence in the
middle of winter
eventually this progressed to disease
which wasn't diagnosed until the
springtime
foreign